this is a production of Cornell
University okay well then uh I'd like to
just take a moment here to to to thank
Dr Taylor uh as well here that I've had
the pleasure of working with him on
number as he mentioned a number of
presentations he' done for us and uh I
know whenever he does make it to a why
it's uh usually a great opportunity to
to go to lunch or something and and
discuss uh things that have changed in
the industry you know the different
Trends and he's uh always uh a wealth of
information on some of the you know the
more specialized SE treatment
applications and some of his research
and uh I can show them a little bit on
what we see on the equipment and so
forth so uh today it's uh kind of a
pleasure to be able to uh to share some
of it without having to get on an
airplane and fly someplace uh so there
are you know some mixed advantages I
guess in the uh situation where
everything seems to be on Zoom these
days but um also I am I am trying out a
few pieces of Technology as is we're
we're we're debating what to do with our
workshops for this next year and uh so
uh we want to be able to do some but
virtually if we need to and um I'm
testing part of that in technology here
today uh so uh we'll uh is is they like
to say you know technolog is great is
all when it works properly so we'll see
where it goes again uh so I can switch
back and forth we'll try to take a break
a couple times during this presentation
at least maybe follow up on the chat and
some other things with it likewise I
apologize if I'm jerking back back and
forth a little bit like this because I
am running uh four monitors here so uh
it uh it's tough to always look at it
and still see it without getting further
back away so with that uh like to go
ahead and uh we'll get started as he
mentioned about an hour and a half of
stuff I like to joke with the students
that we uh do handle in for the academic
classes that uh humans have been
cleaning seed for several thousand years
and we're going to cover all of it the
next you know in this case an hour and a
half uh so frequently highly caffeinated
uh presentation but uh if you can bear
with me and uh we'll take it from there
uh Dr Taylor has mentioned a few of the
things that we do this was the seed
science building uh early on and a floor
plan from it so I spend most of my time
in the elevated part of the building
here or uh right next to it in my office
and um you know there's just a view from
the north side fortunately we don't have
the snow today but that could happen
most any time and uh as you mentioned I
do a lot of seed conditioning workshops
or you know seed processing as it's
known elsewhere in the world but uh we
work with industry on different
uh topics that you would be relevant for
people working in the plants I do a lot
of student lab sessions for various
academic uh Labs where we'll do one or
two labs and a couple of lectures or
something to give them the content
that's relevant to that class we do some
of our own research on seed conditioning
and uh help work with an awful lot of
researchers I I joke that I see a small
piece of a lot of projects that where
they need to clean or sort or treat or
this lately people have been counting
seed like crazy once they got done
shelling this this fall so a little bit
on the workshops um there may be a few
people on here that have been to the
workshops before and if so you know that
uh we have uh the students that work for
me put a poster together at the end of
each year and uh one of the first things
I see people do when they come to the
workshops uh is they they run in to see
if they got on the poster because it's
really a photo montage that the students
put together and uh so there was uh 2018
if anybody happened to be there as well
as 2019 and uh they're really not a
highly technical poster just a lot of
fun and uh I I joke that the students
take a lot of photos because if you fill
the poster with pictures you don't have
to write very much so uh with that today
what I'd like to take uh some time to do
is to kind of review more or less in
this order a few basic concept this is
kind of uh seed conditioning 101 but uh
we're going to be talking about uh uh
some of the concepts that are involved
here a little bit on handling a little
bit on drying and so forth up front
basically some of the Harvest post
Harvest operations that kind of cause
problems sometimes for people and then
most of what we're going to be talking
about is dry granular separation you
know that the things that we're doing to
clean and sort and upgrade the seed and
I'm going to introduce a few quality
control Concepts as we go and again the
whole business on the equipment of going
to show you a little bit on plan
operation some of the key principles
we're really not going to be able to get
intoo adjustments uh much on this time I
I joke sometimes that I have I spend the
entire summer talking about this so I
run out of time then so um the
likelihood of covering everything in an
hour and a half uh isn't real great so
first off you know is you're maybe
working on I know you're an hour ahead
of me so uh you probably on that second
cup of coffee instead of the first but
why are we doing this in the first place
uh if it really has to do with getting
this ready for Market okay if it's Seed
corn which we have plenty of here in
Iowa uh it comes in on the ear it's very
high moisture husks and so forth on it
um certainly not ready to put in the bag
and so a lot of things have to happen to
get that at least cleaned and sized and
sorted and then ultimately treated
uh it'sit something a bit easier uh we
joke here sometimes in Iowa that you
know alternative crops means corn and
soybeans uh realize you've got a more
diverse mix out there fortunately we do
work with a lot of other things in seed
science than just the general field
crops that we'd have here uh but
soybeans again are a bit easier uh we
may have to get splits and weed seeds
and you know moldy discolored seeds
other foreign material out and uh I get
into some food grade products as well so
these were uh dry beans uh the the
little maroon colored ones here are Uki
beans
uh typically for export to Japan but
this happened to be an organic seed lot
where um weed control got out of hand so
if somebody needed a bunch of rag weed
we did develop a process for cleaning
those up for seed so uh again I tend to
take a kind of a broad brush approach
here to seed conditioning and it's
basically the post Harvest operations
that we'd be involved at a plant so
anything from perhaps secondary
threshing a lot of drying um cleaning
things up um I do get into seed
treatment and whatnot as well however uh
that's going to be uh covered in
substantially more detail this
afternoon okay uh there are I understand
you have some people that are doing
stuff that are not just corn and sing so
um when I get into this was flax it's an
indeterminate crop where uh they're not
mature at the same time sometimes the
different grasses may have to be uh
stripped a few times uh things like
fruit or tomatoes you how do you get the
seed out of there you get into
extraction we're not going to cover that
today uh but I just want to bring up you
know many of the issues that would occur
um so we wind up with a range of
different workshops to try to cover you
know those topics um again as Dr Taylor
mentioned I've been hanging around this
business since the early 80s and uh when
I started on this uh a lot of my clients
that I worked with for plant design were
mom and pop type operations that
certainly changed over the years a few
of Midwestern plants here have been
added just to kind of show you the scale
of the operations that we often deal
with so I have the the for I'm fortunate
to be able to work with everyone from
small mom and pop companies to some of
the big
multinationals um
okay if we start just taking a walk
around a seed plant which sort of what
this is we're going to more or less
follow the flow uh the different
components would be you know things
related to you know receiving the
product uh drying and temporary storage
uh there's a lot of handling that goes
on I'm going to just briefly cover you
know mostly the issues that are raised
by that today and uh a little bit on
some physical separation with a lot on
that actually today and then uh again
just introduce the the treating um and
we'll finish with a couple of slides
just to finish our walkthrough on the
plan
um again most of what we're going to be
covering today is a little bit on the
material handling and lots on cleaning
and sorting okay just a couple quick
comments things that go wrong I I said I
work with post Harvest but the typical
complaint that I hear when I'm talking
to seed plant people is that uh the
combine operator did something wrong
okay uh either they beat the seed up or
they didn't clean up properly between uh
varietal contamination is a huge issue
and something that we can't magically
remove unless there's uh some difference
between the two varieties that that we
can use the other big thing I run across
is the need to properly dry and storage
you know the seed uh you know if we can
control the moisture C coming in
properly Air at it uh we can do a lot of
things to help maintain that seed and uh
sometimes you know drying to a safe
level is an important part of it um I I
see too many cases where things go wrong
uh moisture really does matter and uh
you know there's just kind of a list
here I'm not going to go through all of
them but uh things that we wind up
talking about on moisture and uh
sometimes when I have the luxury of
doing this in seed science I can bring
in some of our speakers uh much like Dr
Taylor talked about Cornell speakers we
have Iowa State speakers that'll come in
and hit some of this as well as other
guest instructors so uh then uh the
other big thing again I I work in the
same building is the seed Testing Lab um
they have a lot of uh different tests
that are run but at a plant uh sometimes
we're looking for very simple tests that
are often based on the same physical
properties that we might use in the the
machine so if we're checking a cleaner
we might use hand screens or something
something to to to see if it's doing the
right job uh I mentioned moisture that's
probably the first thing that's checked
some you may be familiar with taking
test weight you know how many pounds per
bushel perhaps you get this from your
moisture meter um we frequently are
looking for broken seed uh testing for
seed coat damage on things like soybeans
here uh we do I mentioned seed counting
earlier that the grad students have been
counting and counting we had seed
counters running literally 40 hours a
week or more uh here the last month but
um you know so the number of seeds per
pound or thousand kernel weight can be
important um sometimes we're grading for
visual defects um depending on what
we're looking for and uh this gets
beyond the scope today but packaged
units and so forth how many what's the
weight of the bag and meeting regulatory
requirements and then I'm an engineer so
we put numbers to about everything but
you know capacity uh percent uh discards
uh yield and whatnot um okay so again
whatever uh mention that there's
typically large volumes of stuff going
through that may not not be the case if
you're dealing with tomatoes or perhaps
pumpkins or something but uh many of the
fuel crops will have a lot of material
handling equipment moving things from
point A to point B depending on where
those points are uh could be elevator
legs going straight up uh belt conveyors
and inclines are horizontal some
technology that's borrowed from the uh
grain industry sometimes for filling
bins a lot of vibratory conveyors within
the towers uh and uh pneumatic conveyors
to blow more often discard but sometimes
other product whatever goes up must come
down so we've got some gravity spouts
and let Downs in here as well okay uh
one big problem with all this mechanical
handling can be damage okay we might
break or hurt the seed somehow um I like
to joke sometimes that U whatever the
gravity separator and the color sorder
or cleaner giveth the U handling system
can take it away so uh we want to be
careful about that again uh soybeans are
almost a poster child for mechanical
damage I I joke sometimes if you look at
them too long they might break but um
you see most the studies on it this was
an early one I was involved with uh as
an undergrad actually but uh looking at
uh the the effects through six different
plants over the course of the winter and
sampling everything they tried to
include one screw conveyor at the
beginning in augur and lost over 2%
damage on the average just for that in
germination and um there was also a
moisture effect dry soybeans tend to
break uh more easily than regular
moisture so again moisture matters on
that point too you can overd dry product
and have issues with that so uh probably
the biggest single thing without going
into every possible machine you might
have is that uh this really boils down
to uh not hitting things too fast or
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time so if you can reduce seed velocity
maybe we can reduce drop height we can
slow the machine down uh sometimes we
can use a larger conveyor and run it at
a slower speed to handle the same
capacity if you have uh maybe a screw
conveyor or something in here using a
lowest possible incline don't raise it
up too far and then drop it farther down
and uh again being in the the wrong
place involves you know impact or
abrasion or being crushed by a machine
somehow or being sheared off being cut
by a sharp edge someplace uh so we can
eliminate some of those pinch points
brand new equipment uh frequently has
nice sharp edges coming out of the
factory so running that in for a while
can be useful and uh trying to keep most
of the conveyors running full can be
important that isn't maybe so critical
on belts or something but again um
rubber or plastic contact surfaces if
you hear a lot of noise with stuff
crashing into steel there's usually a
good indicator that there's some damage
as well and most seed companies I work
with do try to modify the conveyors to
avoid these problems for obvious reasons
there is some evidence of soybeans being
uh uh sensitive to cold temperatures and
uh somewhat anecdotal but there's at
least split generation can be worse uh
those of you that happen to get into it
uh we have lots of discussions on how
cold that may be but we'll leave it for
there now okay I promised you we'd spend
most of our time on separation so when I
walk around to plant and again I I did
plant design for for years and uh I joke
that uh um you know you have all these
different parts but no two plants are
ever alike and you put them together in
different sequence depending what you're
trying to do so some of those puzzle
pieces would be things like uh you know
an aspirator perhaps uh we can to
separate things by aerodynamic
properties uh maybe we you know almost
everybody has a cleaner of some sort
that's going to work with uh size and
shape as well as the uh you know
built-in aspirations um we're frequently
doing a lot of sizing in the corn
industry for seed corn the the tower is
frequently called a sizing Tower because
of the how dominant those machines may
be in there if you're dealing with a
spherical product that's more like
soybeans or rape seed uh perhaps we have
spiral separators that would work on how
well it rolls to separate shrivel from
round uh gravity separators are very
important for uh removing maybe low
density seed that may not germinate so
well or other contaminants and uh
finally the the of the common machines
we get into color variation uh things
that you know would be discolored that
could be removed uh optically and this
is kind of an evolving software
technology now of wordss we're really
frequently talking about Optical sorting
uh where they're looking at shape or
other factors okay so just how do these
pieces go together um again I told you
no two plants are really the same but
this was just a flow for uh soybeans and
small grain so uh probably higher chance
that some of you are doing the cereal
grains there uh in which case you know
perhaps we're coming in we may have a
deer I don't see those in all the plants
but uh it's basically some secondary
threshing that goes on before the
cleaner the cleaner takes out most of
the trash depending on what we're
running there's frequently machines that
are somewhat uh industry specific either
an indent to remove uh differences in
length maybe on the serial grains or a
spiral um that might take out the oblong
seed there's various configurations you
might have on a gravity table to uh
separate by density if the color sorder
is there it could be typically ahead of
the treater or sometimes I see it after
the cleaner particularly in a seed corn
plant um treater when it's uh when it
exists for particular process and um you
know some form of packaging here uh
again depends on Market okay a seed corn
plant might look something more like
this the again the biggest difference
here I frequently see the color sort
after the cleaner technically ahead of
the sizers they don't have to run all
the individual uh sizes um numbers of
sizes and scope of these plants will
definitely vary as well but uh it look
something like this you know the biggest
difference in again that Seed corn is
almost always sized for us markets
anyway okay so I work with some of the
engineering students and I like to
explain that the difference here but
with um seed cleaning compared to other
forms of uh you know see manufacturing
that they may be working with is uh
frequently people talk about uh like 3D
printing being an additive process um
whereas something like Machining is a
subtractive process and uh basically if
we're dealing with um um seed cleaning I
mentioned that we have different
machines that are separating things and
we're basically removing stuff from it
so it's a subtractive process and uh
we're basically carving away at this
thing uh you by removing everything that
we can blow away and everything that's
too big and small and then maybe things
that are the wrong density or things
that are the wrong color until we
hopefully try to remove everything
that's not desirable from the seed that
we want and typically we'll have to use
more than one machine to get there
unless we're just separating I don't
know golf balls from seed or something
so what are we removing and I suspect
most people on here whoops sorry could
uh give me this list but you we're after
the you know foreign material you know
weed seeds uh other crops mechanical
damage we'd prefer not to break it um
varietal contamination is very difficult
to remove and uh then we get into when
we start talking about upgrading
removing lowquality seed you know why is
it bad is typically either uh seed
physiology which uh or or different
pathogens that we may have uh that would
affect it okay um now I I talked about
how we're carving away at things and um
we uh we frequently seem to get into
various histograms uh different
bell-shaped curves and this was a box I
actually built as an undergraduate and
the students found it back found two of
them back a while back and we used these
before we had bar graphs and computers
and so forth and you would basically
drop things through a Sitters of hand
screens and then uh pour each hand
screen content into one of these and it
generated a graph that we could use for
teaching and uh you can see that we get
this bell shaped curve on here again and
those of you who ever worked with screen
selection know that you're trying to
pick the screens to trim the Tails of
that belt shap curve as much as possible
without losing a good seed so uh you
know it's uh interesting at least to uh
to talk about that and uh as we start
talking about things like a gravity
separator you're looking at a density
curve that you're trying to trim on
color sords you're literally seeing this
type of probability information
sometimes shown graphically and that's
you know sometimes how it's set so we're
we're basically going through a sequence
of machines trimming each curve as far
as we can before you lose too much good
seed and then back off of it and then at
the the end if there's still defects we
have to decide what seed what machine
would be the best for removing that
defect and go make the appropriate
adjustments okay uh again uh when we're
talking about uh separation efficiency
uh any theoretical process that we might
have here uh you know a simple one
perhaps just has you know product and
discard good seed and they're rarely
ever 100% efficient uh so when we're
talking about it it's you know it's kind
of like a batting average but you know
what percentage of the defects did we
get uh typically we won't get all of
them um
but uh we can also deal with uh recovery
of good product because one way we can
get most of the defects is to throw a
whole bunch of good seed away but the
economics of that are not good either so
uh you know what's the yield and uh I
like to say that seed plants are
typically between the proverbial rock
and a hard place where quality control
wants to remove all the contaminants and
uh uh the accounting people want them to
keep every good seed and uh those are
kind of conflicting uh results plus
especially when you need it all done
quickly by uh schedule and within budget
uh we get into some things with
separation efficiency I'm going to stay
off most of that today just keep in mind
that getting complete contaminant
removal typically means you have to
remove at least a small amount of good
product okay here was just a
hypothetical graph this is not real data
it's just something I made do uh in a
hotel room at 11 o'clock at night to
explain the idea but if I'm adjusting
some machine maybe it's an aspirator and
uh removal deficiency levels are usually
given from Z to one uh the idea was that
if I turn up that aspirator I can throw
more and more defects away I may not get
all them um but you know I probably
don't want to run clear to the right
because if I look at my yield of good
seed I'm starting to throw good seed
away as I crank up that air um and so
again that there is a way to combine
that but that curve uh varies a lot
depending on application so if you can
keep in mind we're talking about yield
it's what percentage of the good seed we
kept and we're talking about you know
defa removal or efficiencies type thing
it's usually just you how much of the a
particular defect that we got out okay
seed plants usually going to try to run
somewhere in that range uh and a lot of
this is really done uh by experience for
a particular application okay I'd like
to talk again we're dealing with a lot
of equipment operators and so about you
know different tools you know why do we
have the different tools for it and I
mentioned that this is somewhat of a
subtractive process and so much like
wood carving you know you're you're
carving away it and removing things and
so uh you know sometimes at a state fair
or something you'll see this guy with a
chainsaw who's uh making stuff and he
has 10 minutes total to do it in one
tool but if you have more precise tools
you can get better details and uh you a
good operator that understands the
capability of those tools and how and
when to use them can provide Superior
results this statue happens to be just
outside seed science it's George
Washington Carver and U so uh I've got a
series of slides here we're going to
talk about different tools four of them
then I'm going to give you examples on
each one as we go through but uh perhaps
we can come in here and we have an
aspirator okay humans have probably been
blowing light product you know wheat
from chaff or something for longer than
almost anything but uh in this case uh
we're looking at uh you know either
usually an inclined or a vertical column
and U just a difference in how fast that
seed will fall through the Airstream
okay a cleaner combines that again with
some perforated screens and uh typically
will blow some trash away at the
beginning and uh then clean things to
remove you know too large and too small
basically to scalp and sift the product
and um then finish with a second
aspiration that's more precise in order
to get more of the lowquality seeds away
sometimes that's the only machine needed
for simple applications but other times
it's just the beginning of the process
the cleaner almost always takes the bulk
of the the contaminant out okay um
aspirators come in a lot of different
form factors I see quite a few of these
multiple P ones around the Midwest just
for kind of pre- cleaning uh those of
you may be involved in something like
that a dis shaped seed like tomato or
pepper I see these more out in
California so it's uh something that
Peter marks will have seen probably more
often but um you know there's they're
just different configurations of the
same notion depending what they're
trying to accomplish okay um one problem
with just aspirating is that you don't
get big heavy things let's say I have
sticks or corn cobs or something in here
um then I have
uh uh they may not blow away because
they're actually heavier than seed or a
stick May stand upright and fall down
through the column of air so uh one
simple way that uh was done to get
things that are grossly larger quite a
bit bigger than the seat itself uh was a
scalping reel and this basically is just
a uh rotating wire reel and the seeds
being poured through this thing from the
top while it rotates slowly and uh
conveys the large product like corn cobs
or or stocks or something off the top
it's just a rough D sticking type
process but uh that combination uh helps
substantially they used to be in all the
corn plants I see them a lot in soybean
facilities now for removing pods that
would give them trouble otherwise okay
um then here's an old diagram of a small
cleaner usually there's at least two
screens to remove things that are again
too small or too big and uh some small
machines here with just different uh
examples of things that uh would be done
to remove some of those contaminants and
uh the components of it again we've
mentioned that there's usually an upper
air or some form of a preaspiration um
to get the light trashed there's the
scalping screens that are the oversized
product um different sifting or grading
screens again undersized and finishing
up in an
aspiration okay
um okay what what comes out again this
was uh an example here with soybeans
again those the you can see kind of the
the light trash that was blown away to
begin with i frequently have students
asking me why uh you know these pods
didn't blow away and uh well you up here
and uh that's basically because they're
seed in them they they're heavy enough
that they wouldn't blow away easily
we've got uh you know undersized
material which are usually splits or
weed seeds on on a dcot like soybeans um
things that we can blow away again low
quality and uh the good there's still a
split here there's some Merit to some
additional equipment as we'll see here a
little bit later okay uh Seed corn it
would look something more like that
again those heavy corn cobs and stocks
and so forth or what came away on on a
scalping screen and just for fun I threw
some flax in here uh there happens to be
some serial grains that contaminate left
from the combine probably that we were
removing as uh just due to different
size differences and so forth okay a few
examples of some cleaners uh in in a
seed plant here in the Midwest these may
be the something resembling them in the
middle and it's maybe two stories tall
but uh you get into some smaller
vegetable plants uh this one happens to
be on the west coast and some other
different uh variations of what are
really lab cleaners but sometimes
they're the primary cleaner for a um you
know a small facility if you're
particularly people doing the the high
value seeds um okay uh when we're
dealing with a cleaner the the we can
have basically round hole screens or
slotted screens and uh different
dimensions anlure metric as well the
these happen to be the English
Dimensions but uh when you deal with
something like soybeans uh split removal
is the big thing and so they'll work
with whether the slot is parallel to the
slope or 90 degrees perpendicular to the
slope is a cross slot and we have kind
of a hybrid as well you find in some
soybean plants called a herring bone
slot that's really about the the cross
slot removed splits more efficiently but
doesn't get stick so well the parallel
slot is there for the sticks and uh
usually you see a mix of the two any of
you I mention heard that there're maybe
some folks doing tur turf grass you get
into small seeds frequently you may see
a wire mesh um of either a square or a
rectangular mesh of so many wires per
inch and uh in the seral grains and a
few other things there can be triangular
hole screens using removing things like
basically triangular weed seeds but uh
wild buckwheat or wild Morning Glory
perhaps uh may come out on something
like that again we'll have a mix of
different types of screens depending
what the application may be okay
uh again what we're doing when we're
doing hand screen selection here is
running it through a stack perhaps we
know something about one end or the
other and uh so we can uh basically
figure out where to trim the tail on
that bell-shaped curve uh I like to use
various types of mechanical screen
shakers this is bigger than you would
probably need it it'll handle up to 28
screens because the seed corn
applications we get into but um you know
again trying to remove as much bad and
and keep the good okay now we start
moving into things that would separate
by various dimensions perhaps more
precisely than we could with screens and
uh in this case we have U the uh things
that separate by length which would be
an indent or a disc separator basically
seed short seed fits into a pocket and
uh long seed doesn't and uh as it spins
around it can uh pick more of that out
um the uh again serial grains are the
most common applications but D sticking
other crops can be important I've
mentioned Seed corn sizing sunflowers
are frequently sized with things that
look more like uh like this which is
again a rotating cylinder with in this
case contoured holes to help present
that seed to the opening and uh drop it
through there you know hopefully um more
consistently and uh so two different
machines with different applications
here uh the main difference on the uh uh
the sizing is just the the shape of the
Hole uh that came in here and um okay so
we're dealing with length again uh it's
a short seed and it it fits in the
pocket and gets lifted the long seed
just keeps tumbling as it works its way
down through the length of the machine a
few of you may be familiar with disc
separators I see them more often in
high-capacity wheat or rice seed plants
but in this case the idea is still the
same that we have a short seed fitting
in a pocket uh the short seed is is the
pockets are Now cast into the sides of a
rotating disc and there's a bunch of
these discs maybe 20 seven of them uh 25
inch in diameter or something down
through the machine and as they spin
they lift the short seed away and it
gets tossed out the top basically by by
centrifugal force either one of these is
lifting short from long uh they're very
common for any kind of elongated Seed
where length becomes important or
perhaps you you can't actually see the
difference you know the width and the
the thickness may be the same so a
screen can't actually separate them uh
length uh becomes important for those
types of applications some of you may be
familiar with some of the European
brands that use an offset uh indent in
this case that pocket has been kind of
deformed to one side they're basically
trying to mimic some of the effect that
we can get with a disc and uh in this
here's just an example of one particular
uh brand but the the same Concepts exist
it's just that that offset pocket kind
of helps lift uh maybe an elongated seed
like many of the grasses or serial
grains that they would be cleaning over
there um the folks that are D sticking
might uh worry about reversing cylinders
and other things okay here's just one
fun application um this came into one of
our color sorder workshops and they
wanted to get these dark seeds out of
here there were some weed seeds inside
it that needed to be removed from the
white lettuce uh that they had and um we
had a double of a time getting it sorted
by color but we wound up with something
like this and the way I did it was to
take the sample and run it through a
small indent and uh we got something
that very much resembled a color
separation uh one of the fun Parts here
is some of those weed seeds were
actually uh the bodies of dead insects
that were just missing their uh Wings it
it wouldn't fall down the Chute we'll
talk a little bit more about that on the
color order later okay just a little bit
on disc separators uh probably not a
common thing there but the pockets do
come in different configurations I
certainly wouldn't worry about all the
different designations there but uh
basically there's V Pockets that'll tend
to lift spherical things the name comes
from vetch our pockets that tend to list
in cylindrical things uh the name there
again comes from uh the U um from rice
and uh then the square pockets are
usually What's d sticking sunflowers and
other products here's just a quick
example of that you can see where
they're basically lifting uh the
sunflower and uh the you can see the
sunflower seeds flying through the air
here uh one advantage of an indent or a
disc separator over an indent is that it
has a lot more pockets okay and if you
have to physically lift every seed
you're not going to get a seed in every
pocket so the more Pockets you have the
more capacity you can get and if you're
physically lifting all the seed away
from sticks you start to see the discs
are very big indents the indent has a
better Advantage from a standpoint of um
adjustment okay you can change the speed
and change how much is being lifted so
sometimes I see a mixture of the two
machines for specific
applications okay then we move into
width and thickness again this is done
with a Precision Sizer either the round
holes tend to separate by width uh if
you think of uh how a uh a seed would be
presented to an opening uh if I if I had
a round opening and uh this is my seed
here um basically a round opening if you
think of a manhole falling into it it it
tends to see the width of that seed a
slot tends to see the thickness okay
it's going to fall down through that
slot uh neither one of these tends to do
length that's what the previous machine
was for so uh in this case we have uh
again seed being presented that round
opening for separating by width or to a
slot for separating by thickness and um
then we'll typically have a m multiple
machines in order to get the desired
results okay we have a small sizing
stack in my lab as well as a
two-cylinder
machine but uh this is a just a series
of four single cylinder machines that
look something more like this the sizes
vary because we can change them much
likey wood cleaner screens but in this
case producing four sizes and an
undersiz discard and I want to point out
that depending how many sizes we need if
it's sunflowers perhaps they're five and
they're all done with round or so but
we'll need multiple machines because
every machine is much like a a screen or
a cylinder it produces overs and
throughs so I only have two sizes if I
need more then I have to have a few more
machines okay the number of cylinders at
each point depends on capacity this
small line here uh is based on single
cylinder machines but you know you can
find machines with two four and six and
then beyond that we put more machines in
parallel um and there's some
complications you get into balancing a
sizer stack um I'll just briefly
introduce it here but uh you get beyond
the scope of this presentation it can be
a couple hours in a workshop just to
talk about sizing efficiency and how to
get consistent results from that these
types of things become important
elsewhere in the process you know having
you know consistent sizing not only
helps planting but it makes differences
on your treating uh results and so forth
as well much like removing all the
foreign material becomes important so
right here uh I've mentioned that a
sizing Tower in the midwest contains an
awful lot of sizing equipment here's a
shot in one of the larger of one floor
in a large Seed corn facility here so uh
they do have a few cylinders and
selecting those cylinders beforehand
becomes important so you don't install
them all and then find out you're wrong
and you've got to start changing things
so how do we do that again it's much
like picking screens it can be done with
flat screens typically I'll see people
get a overall distribution with uh with
the the screens and then decide again
what to put in the cleaner and for the
undersize removal and uh then the
tougher part is picking where you're
going to split the sizes so typically
they'll split um the width separation
first perhaps and then the uh thickness
but that can be done in Reverse it's
possible to verify those results with a
laboratory a batch Sizer you know our
other methods there's some Optical
equipment that's being experimented with
as well this is a little bit uh less
clearcut than just the cleaner okay on
the cleaner we know that we're trying to
remove the bad and keep the good in the
case of sizing it's just a question of
how we're sizing the good okay so what
are we going to call large medium and
small uh flat and round and so there's a
little latitude on that sometimes that
varies on end use uh what how much
variability we can have for plant
ability I'm starting to see discussion
on variability for seed treatment and
sometimes it's purely marketing
requirements but U we'll see a different
number of different things again here's
the uh batch Sizer I talked about uh we
use this for some lab things and for
doing small batches and so forth small
lots that we might run into again overs
and throughs so one disadvantage if I
need to make four or five sizes I've got
to run through this a few times um but
uh it's perhaps easier than trying to
fire up the whole Tower and losing the
lot in there someplace okay I mentioned
that there's issues related to balancing
sizers and um so one of the problems we
run into is not only that the uh the
capacity of a round and a slot are
different okay the round has more
capacity than the slot as you can see
here uh this uh this purple up on top is
uh basically the uh uh round hole in
capacities in bushels per hour but uh
the other problem is it also varies
depending on hard hard on how much falls
through okay so the rated capacity of a
sizer is based on 95% falling through so
so basically that means 5% are going
over the top of the cylinder and heading
you know in with the other product uh
we're basically wrong 5% of the time but
um if I push it too fast more product
carries Over the Top If I slow down I'll
get a little higher efficiency so if you
see here as we uh
if so they're rating it at 95% and then
saying that's the capacity that that the
manufacturer say you can get from it uh
your results May Vary in a real plant
and it also varies on percent throughs
so if you think of the difference
between a scalping and a sifting screen
uh if you have almost everything falling
through which would be scalping um the
bulk of the product goes away right away
and there's more time for it to to work
its way down through the cylinder and
search through the remaining product for
the undersized material but if only
small percent falls through much like it
would on a sifting screen in a cleaner
um there's an a lot more product on that
screen and you're going to have to slow
down to give it time to find the
remaining undersized product
um again so the the complication here
has to do with keeping everything
working uh with at a reasonable
efficiency if you overload one of these
machines you know that efficiency may
not be 95% I've seen times when students
are running it and uh it was 60% uh
which means you know 40% of the uh
product that's in the overs is actually
throughs and uh quality control is not
happy so balancing that and getting
getting we even do this in an Agronomy
class where uh we we look at what it
takes to predict the sizes and then what
it takes to uh to you know to evaluate
what's there and how to get those two
numbers to match okay sometimes uh
what's old is new again uh if you went
back uh several decades you'd find Seed
corn plants would have something called
a rocket grater it was uh flat screens
in kind of a rocking motion and
contoured screens that were used for
sizing corn and uh mostly we see the
rotary cylinders because they were more
efficient at uh at the sizes for these
large seeds but um I do see people
people now adapting flat screen cleaners
for sizing it's uh fairly popular due to
some concerns on mechanical damage with
the rotating sizers uh you do have to
slow these down typically you start at
half capacity of what it would be for a
cleaner and then go from there in order
to try to get acceptable efficiency um
but uh you know we do see both of those
methods being used uh pretty heavily uh
through there okay uh I mentioned that
soybeans uh you know are are the other
alternative here in Iowa and uh but this
same type of machine could be used for
almost any spherical type uh separation
I've actually used them for separating
uh round fertilizer pallets from grass
seed uh before and some things so if the
difference is if one of the two products
is roughly spherical uh we may be able
to get it with either a spiral or a belt
the belt has a series of helical flights
and uh the seeds being run down by
gravity and uh basically much like uh
running on on a a curve on the highway
if you drive around it too fast you'll
fly off the round seed basically tends
to fly off the spiral separate greater
flights while the less round product
stays on it and uh the belt is basically
an incline belt uh it's sloped in one or
two directions and the product basically
rolls across it to make the separation
okay um those of you not familiar with
soy beans these are some of the reasons
we may be uh concerned about uh
shriveled or oblong seed um again
typically physiological problems uh some
pathogens as well that would cause it to
not be a nice plump round seed uh in uh
apps we can separate it by how well
it'll roll you can get some of this by
air you can get some with a slotted
screen or other things but typically uh
you know the shape sort here is
important and uh you'll see some Optical
shape that's also developing further but
sometimes we see this able to do things
we can't do with the uh the optical
sorting yet okay um so just a couple
examples here these are different
numbers of cores depending on capacity
you know one two or four and then I see
multiple machines I've been in some seed
large soybean plants that had 40 8 cores
but we also see them used for small Lots
you know laboratory samples and so forth
and for just selecting the the right
geometry for that core uh can be
important now the classic problem that I
hear from uh uh a plant operators is
their spiral doesn't have enough
adjustment okay it's always throwing
away too much or too little and uh so
one thing that we're seeing people
working with are rotary spirals this
idea is pretty simple it's just
basically spinning the core uh with a
small motor and that basically Is Us
just to adjust to change to adjust the
separation we can change the amount
that's being saved or thrown away a four
core just has one motor and a timing
belt inside there to do this and uh just
a quick example here this is uh one of
the two rotaries in our lab and uh
Agronomy lab this fall we did a virtual
lab for the students due to covid-19 and
um so I had some footage and so forth of
this but these are the four different
speeds that we ran the same basically
samples through and kind of almost a uh
visual bar graph this is a different
speeds this is the the basically the the
the round and the flat and uh then as we
shifted we threw less and less more and
more round out basically and got to a
smaller amount of flat and then this was
the uh the product off of those so you
can see the effect of just changing the
speed and uh dramatically difference in
the quality of the discards here this
definitely throwing away too much on
first of these but getting down to a
more reasonable amount here and uh then
uh I happen to have the uh images from
an optical Imaging uh counter that we
use sometimes for evaluating it uh
sometimes you wind up having to uh um
you know measure seeds or try to
quantify them visually or other things
this can take a picture of it and give
us some numbers very fast again this
isn't a replicated trial it was just
things from that Agronomy lab but
basically the round seed off of the 30
RPM the the one that had the smallest
amount thrown away that's probably the
closest to a realistic separation that
basically was our good good seed and
this was our bad so you know we're
getting corn we're getting other things
we're getting what almost looks like a
color sort but it's really based on on
shape and how well it'll roll um so
again uh interesting idea on what
something like that could be adjusted to
do again I'm going to back up here the
idea of trimming that bell-shaped curve
if we can uh you can adjust that easily
with one knob basically move the speed
up and down until you throw away as much
bad and you start to see too much good
in there and you back off a bit okay uh
when I work with the uh food grade
soybean people I see a lot of belt
separators um for export to Japan but uh
in in simplest form it's just a this
Draper belt it's down here at the bottom
is a single slope the seeds put in in
the middle uh it's run the belt is
running up the hill the round seeds
basically roll down the hill and the
less round ones go over the top I
sometimes say that this is much like uh
trying to run down and up escalator if
you're in good shape you can run down
the escalator if you're not in good
shape it'll take you over the top okay
um most of the newer ones I see are
slope two directions and uh you'll see
that on the next slide as well but the
idea here is that uh the seed basically
the round stuff can run across the belt
the belt is running here towards the
right the round product comes down the
flat product comes over and sometimes we
can make some intermediate fractions as
well the large machines for food grade
beans are basically multiple belts in
parallel that's really just about
capacity okay uh few samples this is a
small single belt unit that we have
running some soybeans at this point it
was still on a uh running gear outside
it's in the facility now but uh this is
one waist basket full of Sobe and uh the
output from it okay so you can see
there's a small amount of flat and
oblong and then progressively more as we
get into this so the the round is
obviously the good aalong is probably
going to be good for most applications
other than the Japanese assure me they
don't taste as well um the uh discard
you know would be something like this so
you there could be a debate on something
along that line but most people are
definitely going to discard those uh uh
the splits that we'd have down in here
uh these two sometimes I see a valve or
something so they could the operator can
quickly make a decision on those it's a
more precise separation than the spiral
but it's larger and more expensive and
less capacity okay then as we start
dealing with things that would be used
for upgrading seed um these two are work
on completely different principles but
we'll see gravity separators and color
sords um we have seven gravities in our
fac and uh three color sords now but
more that come and visit us during the
summer so uh there's a lot of interest
in what can be done for those types of
things these are both finishing machines
they are normally toward the end of the
line they should never really be ahead
of your cleaner uh but um it's um it's
some things that we're going to get into
on it we're at a is there a uh I I got
the chat window off here right now are
there uh any questions maybe anyone that
him or somebody's got questions that I
should deal with here before we uh give
you a just a short break um here's the
chat okay I don't have any does anyone
have any questions just take a break
here while I grab some coffee and we'll
continue sure you know obviously Allen
is you know has tremendous depth of it
information as well as experience with a
lot of different cropping uh systems as
well as just all this different type of
equipment so if you have something in
your own particular Seed Company sorting
questions uh he he's he's the one to ask
so please feel free to jump in here
while while he at least has a chance to
rest his vocal
cords
um let me just jump in and this this is
more of a of a grain question uh you
know hemp is a big thing for us here at
Cornell and uh so we have an impact
hauler which would be a small commercial
scale just and again is to get the hemp
hearts out which should be used as a as
a food type of a
situation so since hemp grain and hemp
seed are about the same so I got
involved and wet equipment to use and
things like that which we've already
purchased a year or so ago the first
thing and even with hemp seed the seed
companies are not doing a very good job
at all of sizing the seed so we're
getting a fair range there so I feel
like one of the first steps I need to do
is to go ahead and and to get this size
but the main piece of equipment is the
impact huler so we're using a fosberg
unit which would be one of their smaller
commercial size so our challenge is is
you know hemp is a oil seed with like
35% oil seed so you can run this stuff
and all of a sudden you're kind of just
making a an oil seed C inside of the of
the huler so I think we just need to be
very careful how fast we're running this
thing and things like that or else like
I said is the seeds I don't know how
close they would be to like a baby
soybean or say but but it's a very high
oil and when that you fracture off that
parac carp paracap is just like a
sunflower basically very hard that these
things can get you know really just
impacted inside of the impact huler so
so I know you you don't work with hemp
there I know I always been slow in
getting into the whole hemp thing but
but you kind of see the the grain seed
situation that we're dealing with in in
this okay right two things there I I do
wind up with a lot of products that have
dual use and uh some some Summers about
30% of the people at the workshops are
actually doing a food grade product of
some sort but they happen to use much
the same equipment as you indicated hemp
has been kind of a problem here for me
because up until very recently we
couldn't legally bring the stuff to Iowa
uh you could get into trouble and i' I'd
run a blind question off to the
regulatory people and get an email back
in big capital letters that under no way
should I bring it to Iowa State um so we
didn't have you know a write up in the
De Moine register or something over it
but uh the uh uh so I it's I I can't
speak directly a lot of experience with
it sometimes we had to physically take
machines across state lines and order to
run a test and uh the hulling I I I've
done dehulling on other things uh when
we get into some of the nut crops and so
forth um how tough that Hull is is a
huge difference between different seeds
dehulling soybeans just requires a
handling system typically uh but uh
something like this sound and so if you
start breaking seeds uh we've been into
some things for food grade application
dehulling cotton seed which is brutal um
some other spelt or something might be
an issue as well but um usually I wind
up trying to take a light pass and then
recirculate the product back through
somehow so there may be some
opportunities on that we uh perhaps can
discuss that later and uh maybe there's
some things we can look at to help
resolve that problem I don't have a lot
of De huling equipment but there's some
Elsewhere on campus as well that we can
get to and uh other potential
applications okay all right very enough
uh any anybody else have a question
they'd like to to to bring up at this
time to to
Allen or you can put it on the chat just
go ahead and type in anything at this
point
alen uh this is uh Garett Coleman I was
had a quick question this summer when we
were running wheat and you're going to
get into uh uh gravity tables but I was
showing one of the guys that works for
us the difference in test weight going
across the gravity weight uh table from
light to dense and I was using one of
the handheld moisture test that has a
test weight and from the light side it
was almost a point moisture difference
to the Wet Side it was going from like
five to like 127 or 12 eight I guess it
was over a point is that pretty
common it's it's deceiving okay uh you
said this is a handheld moisture meter
okay so you're just you're not you're
you maybe preway a sample or you're just
pouring it into a cup and filling it to
a certain point okay um that moist that
meter is based on capacitance okay the
capacitance of seed it turns out that
that can be correlated with density and
it can correlate with moisture if you
mix both both of them together it's a
problem uh is an undergrad years ago we
managed to prove that we could run uh uh
wet corn 25% moisture corn across the
gravity and the different fractions
would read anywhere from
um 14% to 40 off the same lot that was
supposed to be 25 the air oven samples
came back and they were all basically
within
1% uh plus minus one but uh so we were
basically fooling the moisture meter
because the density differences moisture
meters are not typically calibrated ated
on at least in the 80s were not
calibrated on density and I've got an
idea your machine can be fooled by the
density variation it's much more likely
that the uh that that you're really
seeing a density difference but it's
being reflected in the moisture meter
readings as well since it's not
compensating for that um you will
typically see a a difference in density
what we're usually looking for here and
we'll talk about more curves but the
idea is that if I can get this right
here is that we have a lowered it
product you know toward the light end
it's kind of an incline perhaps uh and
then to a more of a plateau with the
higher density and uh we're trying to
frequently remove the product that's low
density maybe recirculate or do
something else with that intermediate
product and then hopefully keep the good
and maybe we have to remove stones or
something as well uh off the heavy
fraction but yeah density is one of the
big things when you're talking about
gravities I see people frequently
looking at things just visually but
sometimes you'll miss stuff that way uh
if you you don't see the density
difference I've got a couple examples
we'll use to to do that um likewise if
we don't have time if you don't get a
question in here uh my email was at the
beginning and it'll be at the end of
this presentation as well so you're
always welcome to email me things as
well and uh we can help deal with it uh
gravities and color Sor seem to be
something I talk about a lot the
students joke sometimes that you could
wind up the key in my back and I'll
start mechanically telling you about
gravities and color orders so um they'
be an important topic in the
business other
questions probably we'll just let you
get back into your your presentation too
but uh again start thinking about these
questions and again you know
there's you can see the tremendous
amount of experience and like I said
what you think is oh well we have a
moisture gradient well it's it's like I
said it's confounded with the density of
the of the product so that was that's
really really neat insight there so
thank you after we did those tests in
the 80s um I was working with uh Dr
Charles herberg at Iowa State at the and
uh there's some more history there but
let's just say later on the moisture
meters came out that uh would take when
the moisture meter started taking test
weight it's because they're attempting
to compensate for the effect of density
differences on that and we basically
just showed how aggravated it could be
uh when we were playing with it um so
anyway back to the uh gravities and
color orders things that are upgrading
it and it depends a little bit on you
know you I frequently see people
thinking that these are somehow
interchangeable um because maybe they
see the same defect coming out in either
one and it depends on what the problem
was you know back to physiology and
pathology does it affect the density
does it affect the color maybe it
affects both if it affects both we might
be able to get them with either one uh
but sometimes density is more important
or color can be um you know color if
I've got purple stain on soybeans I
really can only get it with the color
but there's times when low density seed
comes out unfortunately if it's only low
density humans aren't very good at
seeing that so I get into this argument
we have an on on going debate in the
midwest on you know do we replace the
gravity with a color order and things
and that might make some sense in
soybean but for surely that weed example
he had would probably be the wrong
choice um for that okay um okay then uh
so if we start talking about uh you
gravity separators and D Stoners both
separate with a fluidized bed to kind of
differentiate it from an aspirator that
might blow the low density away um in
this case we're going to float a layer
of uh fluidized product across and
basically float the light from the heavy
a d Stoner uh is the name implies
basically removes the uh um heavy
product Stone soil pads you know lumps
of dirt or other things that might be in
there uh whereas the gravity provides
more of a continuous range from light to
heavy and we get into this decision on
where we're going to cut and try to keep
and throw away uh we start talking about
density everything we've talked about
here so far is bulk density it's test
weight uh that's done with a test weight
apparatus but then
the moisture meters are actually
calibrated against something like this
in order to give you that number the
bulk density does kind of in since
you're just filling a volume like a pint
or a quart cup uh for setting of gravity
I've actually used coffee cans and
weighed them if we didn't have anything
else available but uh particle density
tries to remove the void spaces you know
what's the density of the seed itself uh
it's a little harder to measure and uh
actually a little less useful in most
seed applications we use it more for
research and we're trying to determine
what's you know because you can do it on
individual seeds if necessary and uh you
can remove the size and shape effects
and there's a term called specific
gravity I bring it up here it's it's
really the particle or the seed density
relative to water it's just a number
that's greater than or less than one if
it's greater than one which is most
seeds it'll it'll sink in water if it's
less than one it'll float uh if it was
one it's the same density as water but
it's interesting because the term
gravity table or gravity separator
actually comes from the term specific
gravity however on large seeds the
density separation is really more of a
weight separation it comes closer to
that than it does to specific gravity
okay how does this thing work some of
you very familiar with it you know that
you shouldn't have it boiling on the
deck and so forth but uh not physically
boiling just bubbling but uh basically
if I have a little
hypothetical um bin full of seed here
with air flow straighteners and a fan
that can deliver any amount of air I
need if I turn on the fan low maybe I
can dry it or aate it but I'm not going
to separate anything um maybe some hulls
um is I after a Goldilocks Point here we
want the point where there's enough air
that it starts to uh basically become
buoyant uh it'll start to lift and and
fluidize the product make it act like a
liquid at that point the heavy product
sinks to the bottom and those heavy
particles displace the light ones and
and cause a vertical stratification
we've got to get this to happen before
we can get the separation some air is
good but more is not better uh if I put
too much it's going to tend to bubble
and uh basically mix this um
the whole fluidized layer together and I
lose the stratification that's why that
they always tell the operators not to uh
to use too much air um the other problem
with excessive air is it tends to lift
the uh seed away from the deck and you
lose friction with the deck and it's
harder to get the seed to climb up the
hill I also want to point out that this
whole this type of a separation depends
on the interaction between those two
particles so there's no way to gravity
separate one seed by this method um and
it it has an effect on small Lots so
sometimes you don't have enough product
to cover the de
and so you know we have an assortment of
different sizes of gravities for some of
that same reason but other times you
physically can't get down to that small
amount quick idea on a Don Stoner and
again it's a single slope uh compared to
a dual slope system uh much like I saw
on belts but uh the idea here is that we
have a maybe a wire mesh reciprocating
deck and it's uh shaking in such a way
that it will tend to uh move the seed
whatever is touching the deck will tend
to move up the hill um the uh f put seed
on at least three seeds deep uh but
maybe more depending on the application
in the machine and I bring air flow
through their perpendicular to the deck
and I basically stratify this okay I get
that right amount of air flow I
magically get the Goldilocks point of
you know where I can stratify the
product the lights on top the Heavies
are on the bottom and they're touching
the deck they get conveyed up the hill
uh and the lights basically float
downhill much like a sled on a snowy
hill or something that you might have
and they're just floating downward and
uh so they're a bit counterintuitive and
the heavy go up and light things go down
I've had students look at me because
they're sure I lost my marbles or
something through and uh in this case I
didn't completely remove all doubt
perhaps but um a gravity is going to
look much the same except that now I
introduce another slope this was uh the
second of three Olivers that have been
in our our plant but uh the idea that
we're going to be bringing this product
uh you know across here um this is the U
top view the highest corner is here so
the slope that you saw over here on this
uh cross-section is vertically through
this diagram okay so as it's shaking
it's tending to take the Heavies and
move them up the hill uh as we put
product on there's about maybe a two
degree slope along the length and so as
the shakes it just sort of walks its
down a fluidized product has uh a
relatively low angular Repose and so
it'll gradually travel down the length
of this if I increase that slope it'll
travel down faster the net result is
that I get a range here again from light
to heavy and then I'm setting these
Gates perhaps to try to decide what to
keep and uh what to throw away
um okay um there's our slope this was
some really bad soybeans that were
rejected uh from for an organic seed lot
for Japan but uh you can see the dark
colored seed in here this case I was
pushing that machine really too fast but
you can kind of see a curve that shows
up that curve really should come down
more like this and follow this this this
part um but you can kind of see we're
again we're rest stratify it and we're
moving this product down I'll show you
that a little bit more on some Brom
grass but I want to point point out that
this separation is not purely um based
on density it uh if it if everything was
the same size and shape it basically
would be uh but if it varied if maybe
it's made out of plastic it's candy corn
or plastic soybeans or something then
basically the large seeds will sink to
the bottom and displace the small ones
and you'll get a size separation uh if
there's a shape difference like we' have
on corn where you could have flat or
plump round seeds the plump ones will
tend to go to the deck and displace the
others if you mix that together the
separation is tough to predict uh
sometimes you can get a usable
separation but this is one reason that
the seed corn company's size product in
addition to plant ability is that it
does gravity separate better uh with at
least a few
sizes okay uh promised you brome grass
slide this is an older one with a cloth
deck uh running uh Native PR grass
basically across so uh there's a
stratification Zone you can kind of see
the colors on this perhaps but uh we've
got to stratify it once it's been
stratified the lights will start to go
down and then again this is a a large
difference in density so you can see it
come down pretty quickly and then follow
the light edge I have progressively
heavier product coming out I was also
taking some product off the stone trap
here so uh we had um some waste baskets
of product here and I shot this picture
these are not Stones these are actually
product that uh um has been excessively
brushed okay when this product came
through it had some secondary threshing
going on it would be rubbed against a
you know brushing machine and um if you
took the uh
uh remove the parac cartp basically have
just the kopsis left the kernel inside
is what you have here and then basically
light hulls and it was interesting that
these hulls were uh actually aspirated
several times before they got to the
gravity and we still had not removed
them the gravity takes them out pretty
easily just a quick example here of what
those look like here's those light hulls
only about 4% of these were even filled
but a gravity uh it's it's tough for
something to stay standing vertically
it'll fall over and then I could
separate it uh that whereas it might
fall this way through the aspiration and
again you can see the heavy ones that
were excessively uh brushed they're only
about 3% they're a lot heavier in terms
of test weight than uh than my hulls
would be so there was an obvious
solution to take you know the choice to
remove these you start to get into some
debatable issues on the rest of
this um couple historical diagrams here
on why uh we use gravities and soybeans
and corn um some that same project I
showed you for the mechanical damage
concluded that the biggest single
difference in germination Improvement
for the soybeans was the gravity table
um the uh in corn This was um probably
some 7s eror material but there's some
light product and if you could remove
this you could basically raise the
average germination the balance of the
lot this is kind of a numbers game
because these are not all dead in this
case they were 76% but if what you could
remove would slightly improve the
germination of something like this the
the numbers are more dramatic when you
get into some of the vegetable seeds
here was uh some onion seed and this is
upgrading onions okay when you first run
anion seed through it you get a lot of
foreign material that comes out but uh
if the germination is not good enough
oops we've got to run it back over the
gravity and cut some more maybe we cut
20 or 30% in order to get something
that's marketable because the
germination is just not high enough I
see the same thing on carrots and some
other vegetables but um there's no real
color difference here but if you look
and this is just done with a little toy
gravity practically it's not even a very
good separation but my light is more
like uh 23% versus 64 a big gravity
probably would have gotten at least a
little bit of product here off the you
know about 80% this is just blowing that
up looking at it closer again very
little visual difference but definitely
a density difference and uh here's just
a quick shot of some uh the the roll
towels basically looking at the
germination sample for the light uh
versus uh the heavy product here um so
uh again the numbers weren't dramatic
but it can see a difference that density
would make in viability okay uh here's
another one that was interesting not
replicated but I have some really nice
looking sweet corn that came through and
we gravity separated it and separated it
by density you know measured the density
differences on this curve that we talked
about and oops I I I realized I had 25%
of the product I'd removed um so we did
some things and made it into five and
then Blended them back you know a
miracle kind of occurred and we came
back but got it back to three fractions
and then uh thought it'd be interesting
to show you the uh the results from the
germination trays so basically from uh
light to heavy this was about 54 % this
is about 94 94 95 and uh there's a
difference in Vigor as well on it now
I'm going to warn you the sweet corn and
yellow Dent are uh certainly not the
same uh sweet corn tends to have more
problems but we had tried colored
sorting this there really was very
little visual difference to be had but a
big difference for density okay
sometimes contaminants might come out we
had a Serial grain question here on
wheat uh we frequently see uh Urgot and
wheat or barley or rye was the classic
problem with Urgot um have a lot of time
to get into it today but in food grade
products uh Google ergotism and uh
you'll you'll find some interesting
things um there it's it's a bad idea to
have this stuff in feed and food okay
and this was looking at separating Urgot
by density and uh we were looking at uh
in this case is they were looking at
different lots and basically the uh what
it came out after the cleaner is the
blue and the percent Urgot and uh the
red is the gravity heavy which it did
not get to zero but it removed the bulk
of it the gravity lights have a lot of
so don't feed that to your neighbor's
horse uh something that effect but uh
we've done a uh it can be very very
effective at removing that again
sometimes when we're getting uh things
like Urgot or if we have some of the mot
toxins perhaps apoxin and corn or peanut
uh if you get into you know vomitoxin
perhaps you have to be a little careful
if the if the overall lot was not safe
for feeding food and now we concentrate
it it can be substantially worse we see
that even aggravated if it's corn going
to an ethanol plant because the uh the
fumonisin don't go away they just get
basically tripled as far as the percent
level once the starch goes away so uh
other diseases on corn this was just
showing uh the effect of uh sizing and
gravity separating so basically have
four sizes here and then gravity uh
lights mediums and Heavies and uh we'll
cut to the chase here but in this
research they found that on that
particular lot that they were working
with they were getting about uh
3.2% of the uh uh the seed in that
particular size in the lights for the
small round but it was about 40% of the
infected seed for
fusarium um so it it kind of shows you
this advantage of sizing and uh density
separation uh together we'll um okay
when you start talking about gravities
you'll see different shapes I mentioned
that there's seven different machines
with triangular and trapezoidal and
rectangular decks uh in our lab they
have different purposes um but uh I have
to teach people how to run this
assortment of different machines the
first thing we look for is which way is
the shake going if you overlay the uh
trapezoidal machine like this one with
the rectangular so that the deck motion
is in the same direction it's much
easier to understand what's going on so
perhaps we have a rectangular deck like
the one I've been showing you it's uh
this sort of a shape the conventional
wisdom is that provides a longer travel
path for the uh light seed and does a
more efficient job of separating the
light which is usually what we're trying
to remove if we're trying to just get a
you know like on a lot of the fuel crops
or other things if we're after the heavy
product sometimes we see the trapezoids
these used to be very common for corn
for some historical reasons as well but
uh longer travel path for the heavy uh
again this I see them a lot in vegetable
plants yet uh where they're trying to uh
get you they're trying to salvage some
product from a lot that's uh perhaps
inadequate
otherwise okay uh here's an old video
1988 uh showing uh the the first Oliver
that was in our lab uh running
um and uh you'll see some product again
coming in uh from the top here the inlet
stratifies you can kind of see the
lights coming down over here and then a
range from the light up to the heavier
product uh as this migrates down through
the deck if I uh uh get Brian Fischer I
believe thre that uh that's that's
actually a Nightshade Berry but we do
the same thing type of thing today with
a uh roasted Coffee Bean um but uh
they'll take off and they'll just float
down here you can see the lights uh
it'll work its way the reason that's
blinking is not your system it's a very
short video in a loop so um case you
hadn't seen one of those run okay now we
do all the things to try to adjust it we
we have full day or now we were trying
to do a two-day workshop on gravities
this year before covid came around but
um once you separate it there's
sometimes the efficiencies this isn't
good enough we know that if we have a
range from light to heavy that you know
if if this is good and that's bad um
somewhere in the middle is intermediate
uh mediocre product and so it's a
question if that's a mix of good and bad
or if it's uh just mediocre if it's just
if it's just mediocre running it in
circles isn't going to make it better um
if it's a mix of good and bad maybe we
can recover um the good so um the
traditionally um we'll just simply cut
it okay uh on small Lots but and I see a
few companies that will store that
middling and do something else with it
that typically means they have another
use for it okay it's you can never
really add it back to the same lot lever
uh the most common thing was much like
the little forsberg you see here where
it's uh recirculated over the deck that
was a trapezoidal deck there's a short
travel path for the lights and it
wouldn't be completely separated and by
bringing that back around it gave it
another chance basically to separate out
I see a lot of that on Seed corn small
lots and so forth uh when you get into
the larger volume field crops I
frequently see a second Gravity used
maybe they bought a big new Gravity and
they used the older gravity to recover
the midling sometimes I'll see a color
sorder or a belt separator used if uh if
you can imagine imagine like if the only
thing wrong with the middling product
was it had dark seed in it a small color
sorder might be able to recover that um
so biggest thing if you are
recirculating this product try to
minimize the amount that's recirculating
I've been to plants where 50% of the
product from the gravity is running back
over the same Gravity the gravity is
overloaded it's not doing a good job
maybe it should be 10 or 15% that
depends on the application but you can
definitely overdo
recirculation um okay um any any gravity
separator questions while I'm here I can
assure you there's plenty of slides but
uh are there other things that we should
cover
here we had a good test weight question
before if not I'm going to go ahead and
plow into color sords um again probably
a little less of this I don't know how
many of them are out there in your
Market we see plenty of them going into
corn plants and they're gradually going
into soybean plants as well the first
first ones I did were actually for
popcorn food grade product again trying
to get things out for retail uh I
frequently show things like these
rejects the the accepts and rejects are
actually the two streams off of a color
sorter it's necessarily good and bad but
usually the rejects are the bad um the
the Junior High kids will tell me these
are gross and they would never want them
in their package at the store so uh you
can see why there was an advantage to
sorting that product up front uh foreign
material is the other big reason for
popcorn but uh there's happens to be
sataki and what we're sortex or ber
machine here I have several of those in
our lab the other machines tend to visit
so you're going to see those more often
in this uh but uh you know that isn't
necessarily endorsement or disadvantage
of one or the other so I have lots of
pictures of other slides but not enough
time to show them all okay um so when
we're dealing with color sords we're
dealing with some interaction of light
you know we dealt with gravities you
know on density and screens with size or
perhaps but you know you can have
different parts the electromagnetic
spectrum and uh in this case perhaps uh
most of it's going to be visible light
because that's what we can see it's also
going to be reflected light because if
you're looking at the surface of the
seed you're seeing light reflect from
that surface and uh so if we're trying
to get discolored defects uh that's we
want something similar but I do see
translucent sorts occasionally where the
light goes through it we're basically
candling it I see a fair amount of neur
INF fored at this point that's primarily
foreign material removal but uh that's
an area where seeds are or the machines
are evolving pretty fast there's been a
few UV machines that would use a
fluorescent typ swort as well um but um
we'll focus mostly on visible today and
uh you may remember from high school
physics that if you had a uh a prism you
could separate visible light like what's
coming from the window over here uh into
different colors and those correspond to
different wavelengths of light um so we
can pick a certain wavelength perhaps
and you accentuate the contrast uh and
then use combinations of them to improve
our separation uh we're dealing with
something in color separation so uh it's
a light and dark it's not always as easy
as this one I like to joke with the
students here that we've got a seed
identification quiz that happens to be
roasted in green coffee beans uh when
that lot came in it was 1,200 pounds of
it I've had upwards I've had coffee
beans in about six times uh the biggest
lot was 5,000 pounds so our idea of a
samples a bit bigger than the rest of
the
building but this is actually an
interesting separation it smells great
going through the tower uh we can get
discolored seed because that's what
we're doing it's rarely ever This Clean
Cut okay uh usually you need something
much more subtle uh broken seed depends
on whether there's actually a color
difference I've seen where you could
maybe pick up a shadow you know off a
shriveled seed but uh the a straight
color sorder is just looking for color
differences it doesn't really see
density but sometimes you can remove low
density if it's off also discolored if
there's an overlap in those two curves
this is one example where a gravity will
give you almost a straight line because
there's a huge difference in the density
of those two products on the roasted is
a lot lighter moisture's been removed
but um
the uh then maybe we finish up with a
color sorder or you can do it all in a
color sorder but it'll take several
passes okay uh if it's a 50/50 mix is
what that was okay so couple quick seed
examples here this is soybeans uh if you
don't happen to run across those in your
territory uh but uh very colorful
product it's one reason I see people
trying to use just you know they'll use
like a cleaner and then a spiral or a
belt and a color sorder perhaps but uh
you can see some of the purple stain in
here it's a physiological
defect uh but immatures other things uh
I've had students joke that they were
going to put this in a little fancy
bottle and tie a ribbon around it and
sell it at Walmart um might bring more
than the seed but uh Farmers Market
perhaps but uh in corn we're typically
removing darks or maybe some brights
which is tricky because there's bright
Parts on the yellow Dent corn as well in
Iowa we have lots and lots of yellow
Dent pollen floating around and during
the summer and uh so one common thing we
have if it's other types of corn classes
of corn we can be frequently removing
yellow Dent from white corn or from Red
corn or from blue corn or orange corn uh
whatever other kinds of corn we might
have out there because they've been
cross-contaminated with the yellow Dent
pollen um another big Advantage I
mentioned that a gravity can't run very
small Lots because you can't cover the
deck adequately uh a color sorter can
theoretically color sort individual
seeds Okay so we're looking at uh
actually a small lot here uh this they
would use these for breeding
applications but that was the the
student doing this for three years was
running 800 to a thousand of those lots
through a color sorder that we tweak for
small lots and uh could do it more
consistently than he could do it
individually okay uh we had a wheat
question before this is separating white
and red classes of wheat uh for a
breeding application maybe only five
bushels total but trying to get it as
close as possible to Pure okay uh
sunflowers uh we're dealing here with
taking a a black seed out of a black
defect in some cases so uh this was a
case were near infrared because they use
both visible light and near infrared and
sometimes a few more combinations uh the
bane of this is usually something called
scor roia it's a black defect that by
the time it reaches the color sorder is
the same size and shape and density as
the seed itself and so uh and it's kind
of bad in confectionary and uh for
pathological reasons as well but can be
removed with reasonable uh efficiency
okay uh then you can also get spot
defects uh this was uh it's a long story
here but basically we're picking out
seeds that had little bug bites that
subsequently became um moldy and uh we
could kick those out as long as the
product is presented towards the camera
a color sorter typically has a camera at
front and rear view if it's turned
sideways it may not see that okay so a
couple quick examples I mentioned I I I
could show you slides quite a while here
but uh the the larger versions of the
sortex machines that I've shown you look
something more like this uh to where we
might have and they've gone to LED
lights instead of fluorescence like used
to be in most of them um this sataki
machines uh the monochromatic machines
look more like the upper right uh you
start to see some RGB machines which is
really kind of the trend in the business
here right now I want to bring up just a
few things to talk about uh you know as
far as how these things work this I'm
going to go a little bit quick here so
uh bear with me to try to get closer to
lunch but uh the uh uh here's just an
older uh sortex machine and a
cross-section of that so basically you
have a feeder on top you have uh a chute
that basically acceler Ates and
simulates the product as it goes down
past in front of the cameras and uh we
basically try to look at it in the front
rear view and then based on the signal
there's air ejectors that fire at it and
basically blow the U rejects out which
are normally The Bad Seed so you wind up
with two streams of Rejects and accepts
okay um there's three things that any
color sorder has to do uh basically it's
got to convey the product pass the
cameras properly at a single stream so
it can see them all and there's some
issues on trying to go fast enough to
get Capac capity and spaced far enough
apart to get an efficient separation uh
without losing too much yield we have to
detect it and that's where one of the
subsequent slides here gets into the
ability to tell the difference between
good and bad uh and then compare that
signal to something that tells the thing
to remove it and so timing of those air
ejectors is another thing that we talk
quite a bit about uh during the
workshops okay um this next one gets a
little more involved but there's a
signal on the older ones it's a voltage
but there's a signal based on uh on on
the intensity how dark the product Mak
and uh you'll see here machines being
called monochromatic Bic chromatic or
RGB and I just want to help explain that
if you've got someone talking to you
about the differences in machines
because it makes a difference in what
they can separate the traditional
machines had basically one signal we get
back to my bell-shape curve they would
try to uh um Center the U middle of that
bell-shaped curve that's the relative
lightness or darkness of the good
product some's a little darker than the
others they put that in the middle
there's another probability curve
basically for the dark defects or the
light defects and then there's one
number that basically can be adjusted to
tell it how much dark to remove if you
raise that too much you start to carve
into the good seed and uh likewise a
light sort there were some machines that
did an independent sort it's basically
like having two color sorters one after
the other uh basically if it's saw in
dark or if it's saw in light then it
might remove it um and there's a few
combinations this has kind of gone away
to be replaced with what was called a
Bic chromatic or the next step will be
the RGB machines a Bic chromatic machine
allows it to look at the interaction of
those two things so that in addition to
saying that it's dark in one and light
in the other or you can say that you you
can you can look at combinations thereof
um basically red versus green or red
versus blue were common visible spectrum
ones red versus infrared is harder to
show on a PowerPoint slide um the some
of the one of the ones I have basically
has these trip lines that can be used to
box in the good seed and any defect that
goes outside of the the Box basically
tries to be removed um the newer
machines you started to see ooids that
basically surround the good seed and
then uh there were defect perimeters
around here so uh they were different
like these are brights these are darks
maybe uh on this up up here on red
versus green I might have some kind of
reddish type seeds or green immatures or
something you know down on this side and
so we can have different uh defect
classes color defect classes that we can
have individual sensitivities for um it
doesn't take too much to figure out that
if I can plot red versus green or red
versus blue that I could do red green
blue in a cube and have a
three-dimensional color map which is
really the way the RGB machines are
going uh almost every new visible
spectrum machine I see come on the
market today is is an RGB unit okay um
or some more advanced things okay then
um the other thing you'll typically see
people talk about doing a shape sorting
I mentioned this kind of in context
contrast to the spirals but this is a a
two-dimensional profile it depends on
how the seat is oriented uh but you
usually you can look for area it works
better on things like soybean that it
does on corn that could fall this way
soybeans being roughly spherical makes
it a bit easier area and length are
usually pretty useful maybe circularity
depending on product presentation but
it's uh definitely an evolving area
happens quite a bit I mentioned that on
gravities we sometimes Resort the
middling on color sorters this is back
to my uh Infamous uh coffee a single
sort might not get there uh by itself
and so we have to go at it again uh we
frequently recirculate either the good
or the bad product uh depending on what
it is more often they're trying to
recover good from the uh reject in a
commercial plant here in the Midwest so
I'm going to show you just a couple
quick examples at the workshops we can
get into more detail on various
configurations but the idea here was
there was a four module machine running
the primary product the rejects were
then going to the single module machine
the smaller one over here and uh
recovering The Good Seed from the reject
so here's just an example of what that
would look like in a soybean uh facility
so we basically have uh uh kind of a
there's a couple of Handling Systems
happening here but basically we're
sorting it the first time this is an
intermediate product uh that's then
being sorted again uh the accepts from
the the resort are going down here and
you still see that there's some defects
there that actually gets Blended back
with the incoming product give it a
chance to get these remaining darks back
out of there at the end of the day this
is basically our uh discard over here uh
our good seat is over here these two in
the center are just intermediate
products that kind of whirl around
within the
process um okay uh big problem again we
talked about like measuring test weight
on a gravity uh you know how do you tell
if a color sorder is doing its job you
typically have to me you know look at
things uh look at samples so uh I wind
up being uh very interested in you know
automating some of this thing trying to
to be consistent you know humans aren't
consistent from one day to the next or
one operator to the next so we're
gradually doing more work with uh
Optical Imaging to try to help uh make a
better tool that gets results more
quickly uh for that so with that as we
start we've kind of got through our
separation part I want to just uh
mention again I I promised Dr Taylor
there'd be one Traer slide I have some
more that are hidden here but uh this is
an one I put in years back I was happen
to be back there doing some training but
um basically we wind up you most of the
traditional treatments were put on for
pathogen protection um you there's
various things that can be done to
improve improve planner performance uh
as you get into um some of the specialty
seeds you see more uh buildup or
pelleting occurring uh some of that is
gradually migrating into the field crops
as well but uh this happened like sugar
beets would be an example where they'd
make them more spherical or Canola where
they'd make them larger and a rape seed
so they'd plant a little bit better um
but uh you're going to hear a lot more
of that from uh Peter Marx this
afternoon and uh again the whole
business on uh on treating you know to
get good results from your treater
sometimes proper preparation is
important we talked about how uh we have
problem s in the seed plant if that
combine operator didn't do his job or if
the seed came in it was moldy because it
wasn't dried properly when we start
talking about treating uh if we leave a
lot of foreign material in there some of
your treatment's going to stick to that
dust and dirt that's in there uh instead
of the seed you're more likely to get
dust off there's going to be problems uh
that occur uh because of that so we want
to get a a nice clean product to the
treater uh before we go on to it uh the
peling gets to be an interesting example
we got into some things with some flow
seed we're removing uh little hairs uh
from the flower but they didn't think
that was a problem because they don't
germinate well it turns out that uh when
they pellet it the little hairs would
also get pelleted and they look just
like a seed when they got to the seed
lab and they would try to plant them and
by removing the little hairs before they
pelleted their germination results went
up which uh was kind of an interesting
story so with that uh we get into you
know different packaging again beyond
the scope of this but uh various things
may happen from Little foil bags to
large bulk bags or even true bulk out
here winds up in the warehouse and uh
you know Proper Storage conditions again
are important to deliver uh you know
good product and uh you can be subject
for another presentation someday so uh
with that I'll leave you read through
some of this um oops sorry back up I
didn't intend for you to read it that
fast are there uh any questions I can
deal with here quick before I show you
one more slide and then finish up here
for the uh
credits did we put everyone to sleep we
talked about efficiency and you know
like a batting average so if I'm trying
to kill cure insomnia uh are we at
100% is there anyone that's still
awake well I'm awake alen and right I
appreciate this uh this stuff helps with
that this it it doesn't dat but no
please feel free anybody you know is an
attendee to the you know this this is a
a font of information and and a lot of
information but if you have a question
or you can put it in the chat again
Allen is is the person and uh you g to
talk a little bit more about the short
courses then before you wrap up okay
we'll go to this one uh this well we
actually have something called a short
course it was virtual this year uh but
uh the workshops um this is my uh
perhaps optimistic uh schedule we put
together for 2021 there's at this point
a still high probability I have to turn
this into a virtual program or something
we had to cancel these last year uh put
some other things together it gave us an
opportunity to put some other content
and we've been gradually working on
better ways kind of like a little bit of
what you're seeing here today better
ways to deliver you know information
remotely but um at least there's the
type of things that uh we would
typically go through I promise to give
you uh email address and this is the
website for it um we typically try to
formalize these uh dates by the atin
meeting in Chicago which is next week
and also virtually uh but uh I'll share
at least some you know what we we think
think are going to be the dates if the
uh uh if the co situation improves where
people can physically visit us on campus
otherwise uh you could watch that
website and hopefully something else
will show up or drop me an email um
again appreciate your patience here
today uh we'd love like you saw in the
poster it's kind of neat when people can
physically come there but the advantage
of remote delivery is sometimes that we
spend less time on airplanes and uh
maybe a larger audience um
so appreciate that opportunity and uh
that I'm going to I promised Dr I can
come back to this if we need but uh
promise Dr Taylor would' show this at
the end for those of you that might need
some credits right good any questions
while that's up
there yeah this this is your opportunity
with the with alen and again his large
array of knowledge and experience with
so many different seeds and working with
so much different seed cleaning
equipment now it's some some sometimes
it's a case where you know an awful lot
about a very narrow feed field uh we
know I've been I've spent my whole
career pretty much around seed plants
and uh you know some food grade what I
call food grade seeds like you know the
popcorn dry beans serial grains this
type of thing very little in in the the
commodity grain okay I I haven't done a
lot with that I get to some of those
facilities I've refurbished a few of
them but uh you know in the the 22 years
out there working you know designning
plants now I mostly talk about them but
uh we see a a much more diverse array of
different seeds you know hopefully at
some point we can bring the hemp seeds
in and help answer those questions
better but um chestnuts hazelnuts uh
Iowa ones that are being domesticated I
mean a lot of funny things wander
through uh our facility um again a small
part of a bunch of different plants
sometimes learning something for
instance uh we've done some work I
didn't show you here with uh with u with
cerus but it turns out that many of the
methods we had developed for flax worked
and so you can kind of build on what you
learned
okay
okay well this this does take us to noon
and uh again I W to thank you
and give you a a nice thumbs up for your
presentation and a virtual clapping
there
as well so really really appreciate alen
again such such an excellent
presentation with so much information
provided uh I think I have to go back
can listen to the recording sometime
just to to pull out some some individual
information where you were going talking
about some of the equipment so again
thank you so much all right well again I
G to give you a thumbs up on your end
it's it's a neat opportunity to reach we
we get some people in from uh various
companies up there doing pumpkins doing
uh organic uh white corn and things like
this uh um you know some Flint corns and
stuff have come in samples and so forth
and uh We've we've some small family
owned companies have been out uh one of
their sons came out and came to Iowa
State after a workshop uh so uh he's now
an agronomist that's working for one of
the seed companies so um it's it's a
neat opportunity for collaboration and
uh much appreciate that so okay like for
me i' I've got another hour till lunch
but uh you know so I could stay on but I
suspect a you you've got other things
that you'd like to do and I I I would
you know recommend trying to catch that
presentation at one and some of the
others later this afternoon will get
more into product and performance but
the the equip part you get into treating
and things that affect those results uh
you know should be covered and for you
know a range of seeds but that are not
probably just corn so be there either
good thank thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu